hello went welcome to this video this is
coverage for round 11 of the candidates
tournament and 11 means yeah 14 rounds
total it's only four games left yeah
let's see what happened in this round I
think round 11 probably was the most
spectacular round so far and we could
have easily had for decisive games very
very easily so let's get going with the
game Geary Nakamura yeah Giri is on
fifty percent has played ten draws and
still yeah if he wins a game he's in
contention to qualify because the
leaders are just on plus two so we have
you for not giving frequent move but he
can serve with any move and get the
Italian game Nakamura seems very intent
on playing classical openings yeah and
so castles neither 63 86 c 3 a 60 this
is very very usual nowadays and a for
this is all the rage at the moment this
small move i think i'm basically on
record in saying that i don't quite get
what's so special about it but yeah one
ideas is so clear one wants to play this
and possibly Bishop to e3 but still
doesn't feel like black should be in
huge trouble but it is some in this
Italian games with with black I have my
own fair share of experience it's often
not a game where white looks
particularly threatening but it is still
the case that yeah this pawn on c3 is
dominating this night a little bit and
it's sometimes it's a little something
that white has in some lines so what
happened here h3 at six night BTW too so
that night a three idea wasn't really
put into into action 97 by my camera
yeah addressing this thing that I said
that
right on c6 often isn't in such a great
shape 93 and c6 yeah black is now
planning if possible the right moment to
strike with d5 himself yeah give us
retreating getting out of the or the
tempo them it like now plays d5 after he
takes d5 this pawn is hanging now I mean
not that this is unplayable because
there is a funny little tactic that
check should be acknowledged so what
this is the point check wide cannot
actually take but black has to vary a
bit about this pawn so Nakamura went to
Bishop is 6 he also could have played
rook e8 and a couple of things they are
not this is not a position that is very
forcing yeah this is allowing those
doubled pawns and it seems that after
deform Nakamura took and played 25 it
seems that is that this is what he had
in mind when he played Bishop ecigs as a
possible way the game could continue
yeah give me now takes on d5 this is the
the simplest move let's say and it puts
black to the test a little bit and the
interesting factors are after 885 the
normal looking move e takes d5 for black
this is for Nakamura played that this is
actually not that great in the game we
will see that white get some very
annoying pressure after this yeah but
isn't this basically forced them as this
is under pressure it's not black
actually can take when the night that's
a very interesting possibility after
Luke takes 6 9 H for black has very nice
compensation for the pawn
for example if white now decides to
capture and black will take and is
taking this under fire something that
would be for for example green to f6b
should be three and now move like yeah
even Bishop EA does given by the
computer is quite interesting Black has
compensation for the pony f1 porn down
but a very nice night good open files
and why doesn't have a totally clear
plan available yeah black is very very
okay em for the pawn and it's an active
position that's very important to note
in comparison to the game after he takes
to be honest first glance i thought okay
and this this should be okay for black
right he has a decent pawn structure to
pawn islands against three um that
bishop doesn't look so bad it can
currently looks at this but it can also
be reloaded here and i didn't really see
any big issue for black but if you look
at the game you see that there is a big
problem and this is the e5 square white
gets to put a piece on e5 and black has
a hard time to play against it and those
four pawns they are not worth much as
they are very effectively stopped by
whites three pawns in fact we will see a
kind of minority attack later in the
game Queen d3 tempo on the night hun g6
retreats Bishop d2 and now we see
there's this opportunity but also 95
coming yeah and this is surprisingly
awkward yeah this is Nakamura um stri
against it and I think it makes perfect
sense to allow this but now we see that
white gets this excellent night only
five and at the same time black does not
have any adequate square in return
before it's not something that you can
use this black yeah why it's just better
yeah it's just what it is
deform intending b5 with this kind of
minority attack Knight to c8 and Roxy
one was played and now Queen to d8
getting out of the sea farm yeah 96 was
a possibility also maybe that was a bit
tougher it first glance you think that'd
be five is still possible I mean and it
is but there is one point okay black can
of course not take but this is a funny
tactical tribe the point is that night
takes is bad because this oops it's all
of a sudden a very good pin but white
actually can take with this and after TS
takes has a pretty good compensation for
his exchange for example after 95 white
can just continue with with 94 and the
other said the compensation is pretty
pretty good it's not necessarily yeah a
big advantage for white but something
that he probably would like to play the
question is if white actually should
play b5 you can also delay this move
don't have to do it right away maybe 96
Rosa was a better chance this was played
by nakamura and now b5 led to young
blacks pawn structure to being
completely completely am get destroyed I
think those those musait yeah they make
them make some senses no need to look at
the deplane yeah here why should
probably play the move Queen to before
we see something very similar later in
the game the default porn is attacked
and giving place this I think he
probably relied on some syntactic here
but Queen takes d4 that was not play but
I camera but I think this was a possible
move I don't think why it has anything
brilliant here and I mean
the engine basically seeing things that
as well or calculate that as well this
move looks dangerous but black actually
has route takes you three is it
important little resource that's 94
which one isn't anything for wine it on
ya rookies free probably and then yeah
move like winter be too this looks very
dangerous for black but that doesn't
seem to be the win yo man can check here
to go back attending 96 but black can
just move the rook away and okay mean
white OS has has has ideas to to make a
draw this is so active like is this
check is one way to make a and make an
attractive drawn but there's not there's
nothing more it seems so maybe Queen g6
actually was a mistake and now come
where I could have solved his problems
with Queen takes d4 this is a difficult
move forever to play in time pressure so
now give me plays a good regrouping the
night gets it gets improved on to f4 and
we see how difficult blacks a player's
he has to basically shuffle back and
forth while widest just slowly creeping
forward in a way yeah and now black has
to go to a 70 it's it's just pretty ugly
and I can where I decides that he cannot
take this any longer and takes the night
this is the thing that is so strong only
five that piece at you at some point
probably cave in and take yeah and now
this is an excellent position why does
not want to trade any any rooks here of
course and here wants to establish this
strong point and those two are very weak
right age 50 this is well played by Big
E read he goes he six
and look at five yeah in this position
now the night on h5 is quite obviously
hanging and it seems that the best reply
is look to e5 after that why does is
winning the game I guess yeah 96 maybe
white can take and take on d5 and this
kind of position can can arise yeah why
should win with this pawn I mean it's
not going to be like tools and black
resins but that looks like a win however
given now spotted something and went for
it he took on g7 and you can really
picture how him how his mind worked
there he was so eager to get a win in
and get into this tournament right
trying to really get into contention for
first place he spotted this nature 7
idea the ideas after Queen takes to play
rook to e3 but unfortunately for him he
had missed that after rook g5 the queen
is actually hanging and after Queen
takes g7 check black captures with the
rook and is a piece up and will win yeah
amazing yeah he had to basically yeah
pull the plug on this game now he took
with the rook and now to be the queen
threatening to play e7 check so black
blocks that are actually sorry here they
actually agreed to a draw suggested by
Gary um it is it is a draw and draw
position um for example this is a very
likely line where this pawn is very
difficult to to hold him black tries
that then e 7 will do the trick and in
this position nobody can play for win
yeah so a tragic end of this game for
giri who really outplayed nakamura quite
nicely and then basically failed very
close to the finishing line
by overlooking this is rook g5 resource
so he really should have won that game
we cannot really blame him for half
sometimes people blame he is playing
boring or whatever now that he didn't do
any of that he just outplayed his
opponent quite convincingly but then
helped us had this blunder here with
nijah 7 it's the long tournament it's
not to be underestimated it's not like
you just you have just have a single
game somewhere it's it's it's after ten
games plus preparation and so on and I
wonder what kind of order i should take
him i'm going to take aronian spill the
next yep so we gotta slap defense and
this line against witla already has
played that two times in the tournament
so it seems that he has prepared this as
his yeah weapon of choice in this for
this event and he sticks with it which
is saying something yeah if you play it
three times in such an event you really
believe that even against the prepared
player nothing bad should happen yeah we
have this line which we had seen before
in the game against Nakamura but now
Bishop e3 played by Aronian this is a
different setup then played in the
Nakamura game it is however all pretty
normal why pay is the creature to post
the night upon me five and centralize
all this one has been seen before in
games yeah night be 25 to ship see one
yeah the idea of all this is that the
rook here wants to swing over quickly
and this is what aronian is doing and
one one issue I have with this game is
that I'm not totally sure when the
position gets to be yeah I mean black
into trouble is what I'm trying to say
and I'm not totally sure when it gets
serious I mean I'm totally sure that
this is normal okay position for black
it's like this is how you play this this
opening basically a black is blocking on
the d5 square is happy about his night
there it has to sustain this kind of
attack it should be possible really it
should be he took now on c4 and night x
one important thing to understand in
this kind of structure that is closely
related to iqp structures that trading
the light the lighter the light yo the
minor pieces yeah we have heavy pieces
and light pieces no it's minor pieces in
English um they're trading those the the
bishops and nights is usually in favor
of the site playing against those pawns
or playing against IQ that I QP this is
the same thing with those structures
because with just with heavy pieces you
have better chances to pressurize those
pawns the attacking challenges
associated with the pawns they are
stronger with more pieces on the board
so my initial impression was that black
shouldn't be in there bad shape because
he already got two pairs of pieces
traded and one of the pieces was
actually there the King's Bishop that
usually is quite dangerous here on d3 me
um still a couple of moves later white
the tag gets to be really dangerous g6
95-97 Bishop h6 ruki 8 + f4 or looks
logical but this is already a very very
dangerous attack so maybe a little bit
here not in the secret like g6 97
somewhere here there was black probably
has to improve because this is now
getting very dangerous he played Bishop
f8
yeah okay maybe you can play Bishop f6e
or something like that Bishop f8 now
hear this we have a repetition and now
naija for and I think after this like is
in in serious trouble and it's it's it's
a bigger issue than you think at first I
mean clearly white has some attacking
pieces but still you wouldn't believe it
is so dangerous it is however yeah let's
let's start with like normal-looking
moves around looks rook c8 mania looking
at this the issue is that why its attack
gets super strong check King to g7 yeah
if black plays King to f8 after f5 it's
already over as Bishop g5 FG 6 threatens
rook f7 mate and this is end of game so
King g7 has to be played yeah and here
white again gets a strong attack with f5
all pieces yeah participate in the
attack yeah black cannot capture here
for example after Bishop d7 95 we win so
Bishop g5 and now FG six and we see
again rook f7 is in the air night f7 is
in the air whoo and black only has one
move that doesn't lose immediately this
is f five and then night f7 also leads
to a good position for white this is
maybe still better than what was
possible in the game as we replayed age
five yeah aronia now plays Bishop takes
e7 but it seems that the move Knight age
six check would have been extremely
dangerous for black the point is that
after King g7 white has this move h4 and
this is not a super intuitive decision I
think yeah why does kind of yeah
strategically it looks awful but it's
just a fantastic attack and I
don't really know what the black is able
to defend against it the the idea and
this is not super intuitive is actually
look III and then possibly night f7 or
f5 for example I can show you one line
if Quincy seven you know to connect
drugs rupee three things are getting
very very critical already what is black
supposed to play now if it plays let's
say night to be six then f5 is already
killing again now black can not take
with this as in seven tanks or Bishop e7
us is probably even stronger well this
completely impossible and they should
take this i'm just going to recapture
and again this is impossible to stand
the wider tag is super strong um another
line that group c eight comes into
consideration but after you see f5 you
can quickly discard the whole thing this
is Jack absolutely killing and Bishop g5
that's every six again threatening rook
here and black is totally crushed I am
Not sure that there's a defensive to h4
I looked a bit yeah with the engine and
it doesn't find anything basically it
seems to be a pretty much decisive
attack so black has to yeah then there
must be some errors earlier some
mistakes by black but I'm not really
sure whether whether were there I i
added all this move looked fairly
natural so it's not a clear clear thing
to pinpoint yeah ironia didn't do that
he took on his self Queen takes and 95
and okay why it still looks White's
position still looks attractive yeah he
has those active rook and night and
black is under pressure
however if there is no direct direct
blow like a maid or whatever yeah it's
all nice and good then but if you cannot
deliver a final blow it's not so it's
not such a bad position so we're less
finding order or the movie who gets five
was the thread song goes back to age 893
and now black got rid of the last minor
piece in exactly the right moment and as
f takes it's not possible as the rook
takes and queen to d6 that was also
Queen f6 a couple of options so Black
now has reached his goal he's gotten rid
of all the minor pieces and now in you
know if this was a little bit different
yeah let's say the pawn not on h 5 foot
back on 87 then black would start to a
play against those pawns and would be
really a little bit better in this
particular position with h5 being played
and white being so active it is i think
probably equal queen d together threaded
f5 / took it easy to an address russia
three king edger Luke h8 h 5 or sending
so so that is defending this very very
yeah reliably i sees all the threats and
make sure they don't work Queen to be
seven yeah so he gave up this pawn and
it was necessary I could have played be
six instead but he gave up that b7 pawn
however after this this now it actually
makes a mistake this is something that
becomes apparent quick quickly he should
play Queen to a three and directly
getting form or going for counter play
against a three it's important to note
and this is maybe one reason why this
was rejected that
direct attacking continuations here like
yeah let's say let's look at the
sacrifice check if white takes and takes
with the rook it's important to note
that after Queen see one check King f2
Queen d2 and check check check that here
black needs the move Queen to be one
indirectly covering this yeah rook takes
King edge seven is just a draw now this
is like a perpetual not easy to see the
screen be one resource so maybe swidler
was afraid that this this would happen
this is why you played rukka h2c aid but
now there was a second chance for
aronian after i mean he had this night
age six and h4 which i think once you
have found this you're probably on the
road to victory that that tech doesn't
look defensible okay here um aronian
could have played the most age three
addressing the back rank issues and just
continuing the plane and the problem is
that now this kind of counter attack is
just not working as rook takes is six is
going to be played yeah there is no
meaningful counter play now as king edge
2 is completely safe so black cannot
play this in fact only one move as I
mean white is also still threatening to
take material only one move continues
the game that is Quincy six everything
else is even worse and then after d5
takes rook takes white is just playing a
pawn up just like that and there is very
little reason to believe that he could
ever lose the game it's just a flat pawn
yeah he played rugby five whoever and
this is spawning the game to the at work
to an equal position at first
now here yeah note that here this move
was possible but after check jess is an
immediate draw so maybe aronian still
wanted to to try something which is I
mean he was on plus one before that game
so wind would have been fantastic so
probably he just wanted to continue and
all costs try to try to win it it's it's
a time trouble so time trouble issue
also yeah I would be eight and yeah here
aronian is spoiling the whole thing by
playing Queen to e2 he probably had to
play Queen to be one trying to keep it
keep it like that black is already a
little bit easier to play but the
likelihood of a draw is very very high
here yeah for example like h4 rook here
a six and yeah then you can do something
like this and activate with this it will
probably end in some equal ending yeah
we could be one so it's a funny line
actually check yeah and now White has a
couple of options let's see what it's
the easiest way to draw here I only
looked at farm
Jim okay I mean you can always play that
King f3 and Turkey let's do something
something like this and draw this upon
down which but it's not much fun you
probably have something better here
maybe it's just this move and play like
this yeah this should be an easy drawn
yeah why this active yeah this is this
is a pretty clear role um yeah this is
what he should have done it played
Quincy to whatever and this is leading
into big trouble Jack Queen c1 check and
what now yeah you played King f2 and it
looks this looks like a stupid move to
frankly but the alternatives he saw that
f4 is hanging out the alternatives are
not great however I am I mean Queen f
wonders that is the alternative but this
is also not funnier black goes here and
we'll get me five next SC for Hanks the
d4 pawn it's not fun really isn't so I
guess he decided to just drop this one
instead check repetition check yeah and
now smilla after having reached time
control took some time and then find I
found the correct mafia King to g8 nice
one yeah the big idea is that now black
is out of this check so that the black
queen can actually move yeah and now
aronian had to play book f3 that was the
the final opportunity to make a fight
out of it the idea is that here you can
try to escape into the rook ending which
let's say after these moves is better
for black but Luke ending always has
some some some drawing chances yay
especially here you can still hope to
get some yeah two pawns against three
pawns or something if black is some not
playing in perfect lemme it's what he
had had to do he played this however
and now after a six I think it's over
yeah this is getting lost his pawn and
the consequences I just adjust to
Sevilla other jack vporn also is
dangerous and he after Luke a8 and Queen
B to aronia already resigned yeah he
fell apart pretty quickly after his
blondie or move 38 he probably also was
yeah very disappointed by the cause of
the game because it was clear that he
had a strong attack but he certainly
couldn't couldn't deal the the decisive
blow it was a very key game I think for
the tournament if aronia would have won
that he would have been back on + 2
instead he now lost it and its back on
fifty percent which is basically the end
of the tournament I mean almost there's
three rounds left and to win seven but
it seems very unlikely ok the next game
to check is to Palo Caruana let's note
that now we see a new opening for this
for this tournament the symmetrical
englischen it seems that um see far as
one of the clearly fashionable moves on
this event but there seems to be some
kind of unspoken agreement that he five
is the best move and should be played
well not with Caruana empty place a c5
yeah in fact this is something that I
wanted to mention I think that both
caruana and kayaking huh come on a
morsel is a little bit more versatile in
their openings in this event yeah karana
for example played a modern benoni
against their own yanam and yeah
something something more enterprising
then the the standard kind of things
that that they all play in a way okay
tupolev goes for d4 and this is quite
notable him by the way because for a
long time um most white players went
Knight c3 in this position and so do
this is the main move or sometimes g3
but status III is the most common but
wyd really has a hard time
to find anything against black going d5
and this is a line that kawana actually
has in his repertoire here you can
sometimes transpose the Greenfeld type
of things but yeah why it has a couple
of pure English options um but they all
don't seem to be I currently lead to
that much Soda form going for the
opening of the center and pre-empting
any black tea five ideas okay kawana and
took it and now played Knight to c6 here
black also has the option to play if I
this aggressive gambit however I think
this is probably a little bit too yeah a
little bit too loose for such an event
yeah after 95 black ghost eheim and
Bishop to c5 this is something we also
have some objective doubts about blacks
play it's pretty popular with aggressive
players but I don't believe it yeah 96's
more sound 93 in d6 the main line of
this sub variation of the English the
part of course g3 is again the main move
um a 3 is also something that I would
recommend for white players as an
alternative but there are many options
so g33 to be 6 blackest looking for
direct counter play attacking this night
and the night now can go to be 3 or to
be five night to be five is a much
sharper move and played by it apart of
recording also in accordance with his
general stand of chess 95 a Texas pawn
on c4 yeah it's important that white is
some not actually obliged to cover this
pawn in fact he never does he only seeks
for opportunities to yeah give it away
now to get an active play Bishop g2 or
Bishop f4 are the most Bishop g2 is the
more frequently see move and here there
are a couple of options that
how the game could could continue and
one for example is that one thing to
notice that black should not grab this
porn after quita a for what is getting a
very dangerous initiative for that yeah
if black comes back for example yeah
some castles Bishop f4 it's such a super
dangerous gambit position with
everything being active the move Bishop
F form is also very aggressive here you
can immediately see that this is not
working okay but on the other hand what
should black play the normal looking
move d 6 is actually very very dangerous
after for example Bishop to g2 um black
cannot capture on c4 and screen a4 is
oops a huge double or a triple threat if
you want it's a it looks very dangerous
if black goes some a six in this
position Queen a form it's going to be
very very problematic after night ft 7
why twins immediately with the movie 5
this is a funny funny line that will
show it to me by grandma's the last bow
hands and when we did a commentary for
that round together for the ICC this was
from one of his games that he has played
against grandmas indictor fermion it's
really a funny funny line up tonight
takes yeah it's immediately over it's a
double check after pawn takes Bishop
takes why just wins the house yeah again
we have checked our checks so Queen
takes yeah and now just Bishop e3 and
where's the Queen going it has it has no
squares yeah something like a takes the
screen 8 or Quincy for why it takes a
check
nets this whole look yeah we see it's a
tricky line but of course Carolina is
better prepared than that and place that
F to G for attacking on f2 yeah III and
now a six and first impression hmm
shaky-shaky position wyd cannot move the
night as be towards hanging so what is
he supposed to do he's got two moves
actually he's got the move played in the
game Queen a four or h3 this is
something that is also possible leads to
very funny positions after a takes pawn
takes the move Queen c6 is the problem
it takes a look and if white now moves
us rook let's say here then black you
can play this and all the sudden we have
actually very weird perpetuate draw or
perpetual check in a way um yeah funny
lines Queen f4 is the alternative and
probably better upsetting more problems
at least yeah and now kawana place the
very funny looking oof ruka a seven yeah
unpinning threatening this and what
cannot take that route because queen bee
to would attack everything was check
this is a disaster how it cannot do that
at all he actually only has one decent
move and this is the move play but to
part of age three this is a position
that is kind of kind of a little bit
yeah it can be a very tricky to play
over the board I think they both them
were within their preparation somehow it
it's still very difficult to get to
grasp with it taken and now I mean yeah
this night is attacked if it moves g5s
hanging the check doesn't lead to
anything and there's still two nights
hanging really weird so the best move is
what Kara wanna played you played Queen
to c6 attacking this rook yeah and now
what is why it's supposed to do he's
still a piece down and we have to count
correctly so he took the night on g4
just giving away
exchange and now I captured on e5 so if
we do a count now yeah why just got
seven points blacks got six points so
white has a pawn for the exchange and he
has active pieces active bishop active
Queen the weird thing also about this
position is said that black queen is
currently on age one white definitely
has enough for the exchange in Queens is
six bishop de forma that was clearing
the fifth-ranked and attacking the rook
of course so Luke went back a three he
was probably afraid that at some point
the Sun Bishop before could happen after
the Queen trade or the Queen was away
and all this is okay I mean white s
strong compensation yeah King to f8 this
doesn't look like a move your love to
play but if you castle you also don't
feel very safe here in this position so
I understand the point king of eight
long castles and b6 instead of long
castles red also had an interesting
alternative the move c5 this is probably
stronger Black now has some problems
with the coordination of his pieces you
cannot play an easy b6 now anymore for
example how do you get this into the
plane this Bishop I mean d6 okay but
this is a temple and in a position like
that what's an initiative based on his
piece play looks rather dangerous c5 was
a very good alternative to long castles
yeah he castle no be sick so quickly C
fibers taken away and I'd be fine as he
falls hanging Andrew create covering the
DS Simpson porn and possibly preparing a
push of the deep hole yeah in this
position now um probably objectively
best how to
how to say probably objectively best
about the move Knight to the six
spectacular-looking move but in fact
this is the same thing as forcing a draw
in a way threatening made black has to
take the night and Queen takes easily
dismissed as it blunders louse so Bishop
takes and now white was Bishop g7 can
force a perpetual check Jay Jay yeah
this is the the draw so the polyp could
have ended the game right here with 9 26
I think kawana was come on I didn't have
a chance to avoid this this possibility
he had to defend any way from this
opening and yeah he didn't do it the
pile of plate Bishop c3 um I think in
some way this is typical of his play as
always the it's probably one of the most
ambitious players around but also if you
look at the tournament standings he's
totally out of contention for first
place and I think he just wants to play
some interesting games and see that he
can maybe get a winner I mean he doesn't
have a win in this tournament yet which
is pretty awful after yeah ten rounds
for player of his home his status so I
think he just wants to in a way gamble a
little bit yeah play play sharp and see
what happens and the consequence of all
of this movies that after Bishop takes
b5 that good night is taken away and
black invade 7th Queen f31 problem is
now that the proceedings are pretty much
forced the rook is attacked went here to
keep this protected and now Bishop f6
and the bad thing is that this is a good
diagonal for this Bishop what does not
want to trade yeah I mean something like
this even GTX is good with King
to come and then the roof will get into
the play here black is totally fine
totally safe and the bishop pair is also
cut in half so this was play this is a
stronger option King g8 there should be
six relatively best and this rule comes
to this open file yeah the big problem
is that blacks intention is to play age
five at some point like it happened to
your queen age three chicken this was a
little intermezzo and then aged five
like it's slowly getting out of his
somewhat cramped position and the moment
this route gets into the play is the
moment where whites game goes downhill
um around here it gets very difficult to
give white any advice and something like
rocket is seven is probably immediately
losing here and what exactly is your is
your player if you take rook takes white
cannot avoid the Queen trade and this is
yeah also not very nice he tried this
move miss bishop comes to the six but
now we see that both blacks rooks get
extremely active and around here it
really looked like Kara wanna will win
in the next couple of moves yeah I mean
pure counting shows us that black is a
complete exchange up the only thing that
white still has left our tricks and this
is all about this be pawn and those
three against one pawn in some cases
white is able to use this be five point
after tactic we will see some of those
ideas in the game Roxy one is is good
wish it comes to d3 Bishop g5
you should have form yeah here is the
first moment where you can argue about
koalas decision now he plays the move
Bishop to e7 this is not a bad move
objectively speaking but it it gets more
difficult that safe afterwards then
necessary he could have just taken this
and let's say after he takes a foreplay
king at eight and then King to you seven
in this position I think black will win
very easily because there is very little
that white can try this be pawn counter
play that was really i mean the bishop
on f form helped us or not if you
imagine the beep on all of a sudden line
after a four a five starting to run it's
so helpful to have a bishop look at this
promotion square here um i think after a
form Qing Yi seven there is no this is
not quick enough simply look at blacks
rooks they are very active this was a
pretty clean win for Corona okay he went
to e7 which is not as I said objectively
bad it's just that it gets a bit
trickier than it probably needed to be
and now after a 5 comes the real problem
he now can win the game with Kiev a door
with f5 both moves should win king of
eight probably being the more intuitive
one um to get the king somehow involved
or king with 28 after before there's
Bishop to deform yeah I mean the thing
is this is still looking kind of
dangerous him but Jack it is ultimately
not enough king of aids would win f5
also looks like a win stopping possible
Bishop to e force and something like
this gives black-haired to bigger center
to to stand them f5 maybe a move that
irritated him possibly was the capture
him
after takes there's a six and well if
white gets a check in then white can
take however it doesn't really matter
that much black can take Jack and play
like this here black should win even
though you can well this is something
where if you have low very low time you
could maybe fear that still has some
kind of counter play objectively blegh
wins but yeah I'm not quite sure what
what ghost kiwanis or maybe he was just
annoyed that this ruckus am in this in
this bishops diagonally played rookie
one but now looks it too but Apollo and
now blacks task is difficult it really
is the problem is that there is this
counter play with the beep on for
example after Luke takes f to all of a
sudden why it takes him his to exchange
is down but after this b6 and you cannot
stop that pie it's really quite quite
remarkable and yeah this is probably a
very very very awkward moment here you
had everything under control you had an
exchange up and looked like yeah being
on there on the way to to win this
tournament and then all of a sudden used
to start to see lions that could
actually lose for you yeah it's very
tough now to say what's what blacks a
best move is he decided to play g5 with
very little time on the clock I think
the main reason for this was to play a
forcing move and get rid of the e porn
also it takes and takes this this was
played yeah to Parliament Bishop f6 you
know Kara wanna play druke g5 and with
this move offered to draw it is a pretty
yes isn't it too tough a tough call yeah
this is this draw firm I think that he
was probably afraid that after the trend
of the game was
so bad that you would spoil it entirely
if you look at this with the gaff with
together with the engine you could
easily say ah why did she offer draw
isn't black just better yeah probably a
black is better and has still chances
but I understand this decision and
sometimes good to be a yeah not too
ambitious and kind of yeah cut your
losses in a way if you feel like
something's off it's it's often not such
a bad idea to be okay with the draw and
in some situations what is what about
this objectively yeah look 25 white will
play Bishop your form that Bishop is
attacked and e4 has a good square and
the thing is is this can can get
incredibly unclear if black plays the
move rook age five yeah let's say after
be form goes back yeah and some some
normal move let's say a bishop here or
something yeah and a4 a5 is the idea and
this is not clear at all I mean the
exchange is so it's in exchange but
White's bishops are very strong and
those kind of pawns they can be very
very difficult to handle what was
possible or ever seems to be after
Bishop before and the move um yeah just
sucked eggs f2 that was probably
possible after rook takes Bishop takes
takes takes there should be five it
seems that black is better in this
ending and he's just a pawn up and this
pawn structure is so totally rotten but
it seems he's better here which is very
very difficult to call when you when you
are just at the board and don't have the
help of a computer King at eight King
a7s idea and stepping up this Bishop
does a very good job in limiting those
pawns and black can also go at five
however I'm not one hundred percent sure
if is this as a serious winning attempt
so I totally understand
koala did them having playing on in this
kind of position without a clear picture
how to win and then losing it is yeah
this is the worst ever him so he'd made
a draw and preserves all of his chances
there with a plus to score ok the next
game and crucial game of the round is
Anand kayaking and I have to say that
I'm not totally sure what to tell you
about this game in some in some during
the end of it it's it gets very very
very difficult to assess and ok I'm
going to just show you the game and I
can tell you that I looked at one or two
videos about this game already and those
commentators also couldn't really yeah
call it call it definitely ok 97 we ever
have a anti Berlin with d3 and
everything here looks totally totally
normal here black um in this kind of
position in most cases plays the move
Knight g6 supporting this pawn and we
have a position that it's kind of
similar to the GUI ronnian game sorry
given a camera again before had this
night to g66 c6 coming it's always
between equal and slightly better for
why this kind of position karaoke no
other goes d5 yeah going for something
more defined in the center it's a it's a
it's an interesting idea if white is
asleep and does this then he four wins
apiece or if white takes on e5 here then
94 also should lead to a very decent
game for the black player so um what is
why it's supposed to do yeah he took
with the with the night only five and
black took him 92 so unlearned tries to
play this position which is already
rather
simplified yeah with the e-file open it
looks a little bit like a French
exchange um yeah 96 now not a bad move
at all I was still thinking I'm still
thinking that black also could have
taken but maybe he was a little bit
afraid that in a symmetrical position he
falls a bit too too much behind the
development you should note that this is
not such a great bishop it has to be
brought back into the play and this this
takes even more time yeah after Bishop
f5 wyd will capture and play Queen III
and this is can be somewhat somewhat
uncomfortable initiative to deal with
okay kayaking went back and after night
be three plates play dead sea six-month
95 a bit unconventional putting those
nights they don't see where when you
have but it puts some pressure on the
queenside 96 yeah instead of 96 Bishop
f5 still seem possible as after a
possible capture black can still take
with this night yeah the d6 night is
covering the b7 square in fact I'm not
quite sure why Bishop f5 was rejected
it's a totally standard idea and there
doesn't seem to be anything wrong with
it yeah kayak innova went night to g6
and now queen aged 5 and here I think
white probably has a little something
yeah he's more active and this bishop on
c8 stays passive he took on c5 and play
94 this is a very direct approach this
night is attacking the pond and black
tries to simplify even more it's very
difficult now for wire to avoid what
happens I think this is almost forced
and this is I think what kayaking wanted
to go for you wanted this super safe
position that now arises what am I
talking about bishop we form yeah
doesn't look very exciting but what is
why it's supposed to
c5 is hanging and if you play Bishop b3
after some rupee 8 for example Knight
takes pawn takes Queen moves this I mean
this is absolutely nothing for what so I
think what on earth is exactly right he
took here tempo on the Queen Queen moved
and now no g6 and takes between g5 looks
like absolutely nothing this end game
right yeah this is also what the
commentator thought and also what I
thought that this should probably end in
some kind of some kind of draw but well
the game lasted a very long time and
from here we see very very slowly black
um yeah drifting away into getting a
worse and worse position and it's
absolutely difficult at least for me and
also further for the various
commentators to pinpoint where where
exactly was the point where it gets bad
for black we look at a couple of moves
that I will point out some things but
it's it's very difficult and I said to
say the square on d6 and the D file is
the reason why why does having some sort
of pull in the first place still you
wouldn't think it should be enough to
win b3 king of seven group deform yeah
gaining space activating and with rookie
for also having a look at this pawn and
yeah kayaking is very persistent in
keeping this pawn protected sometimes it
can be an idea in positions where you
have roofs and opposite colored bishops
you can sometimes follow this idea of
giving up a pawn if you get the rooks
traded to maybe draw the pure bishop
ending and one idea here could odds
could be according to that concept to
give up that afore pawn
not stick to that however it's not easy
to do even if you say okay I don't
really want that porn it's not helping
me it's not so easy to give it away yeah
let's say what is black supposed to play
then let's say rook c8 or something yeah
white will take what did what are you
doing now we should have five to
activate this year said this ruckus all
of a sudden getting active here like
this and it's not really clear that this
has helped much yeah you can try this
kind of thing but why discovering and
this set did black really benefit from
this it is not totally clear and it's a
difficult decision yeah I mean you're
sitting there and our own a plus to
scoff try to get a world championship
match do you give up the pawn here in
order to defend hmm well kayaking
couldn't do it and really it's not to be
blamed blame for that a for ya he played
rookie seven now here maybe the move g4
was interesting to get pawns traded this
is definitely in blacks interest if we
get pawns traded what I guess wouldn't
have taken but played the move h4 and
this is something that's very hard to
assess is this kind of g4 sorry G 4-h
form if this is really something that
helped black yeah this for example can
become an option now very tough call I
think I rather won't play g4 but yeah
I'm not a super grandmaster lee rookie
seven was played and now wyd went to
play g4 push-up g8 and now we see the
rook is away from the action sorry the
bishop is away from the action and white
gets to move his pawns forward before
yeah Bishop c8 was played push-up g8 was
played I'm sorry and now
five and after b5 um Island sorry
kayaking that's a long day clay I can
played the move look to c 8 um here and
one move earlier it was an idea for
black to play the move 85 maybe this is
one key moment in this in this ending
because after a five black tries to take
and take on a four if white plays this
move then black will take and go a form
and he has a clear counter play with the
airport so it's not totally clear what
why does doing after a five the computer
suggest struck the eighth but after the
capture and rook e8 black has excellent
drawing chances here an ending let's say
like this where y takes the pawn is just
absolutely nothing yeah Black has no
problems here whatsoever does this pawn
structure is a complete wreck maybe a
five was was a key defense a resource
that kayaking should have gone from
Bishop g8o ever and now be five yeah now
it's basically two later if you play a
five now then why does grabbing this
yeah rook c8 and b6f white has made huge
progress with the spawns and now we see
that one of those advanced pawns can
easily prove to be very dangerous to
fight against yeah rook c7 and now black
should not take on since apnea guy
giving wildest pawn on the seventh rank
is is a bad idea and for example your
rook c8 if you try that this rook t7
check it's very very annoying so he kept
it on the board King to f8 and ce4
limiting legs bishop yeah Bishop u6 is
now dropping this pawn I mean not
blundering it he just decided to
that he does not really need this
default born and takes King to f7 and
now f for what has to use all these
forces ticks and rook c8 that was
probably try Atkins intention when he
gave obey the porn now on the next
couple of moves Allen plays very very
nicely he plays at five he also can take
on g5 yes but this is here this is just
a verse a worse version of the game f5
Bishop back only move and now he plays
the very nice move age for this is very
very strong plane if black takes this
and white has root before and the bishop
has very little options here he goes to
eight then Bishop f4 and roop d8 is
already winning or after this there's g5
black is amazingly helpless in this
position on King to the eighth and again
Bishop f4 and fantastic this is a very
nice position YTM will probably just
pick up this poor later and continue to
win this pawn is too too hard yet to
play against yeah g6 was played by Clay
Aiken and no root d4 again back has to
take and takes and here black does not
have the time to take on f5 as again
Bishop f4 wins apiece which means the
bishop had to move and now what got in f
six super dangerous here this pawn um
still it looks like black and put up
resistance and kayaking did he played
and defended this for a very long time
what I cannot tell you and which is
really what is really difficult to do is
if there was a better defense
form for the black player now from here
it's I think actually my hunch is said
why should win and this is also what
what Grandmaster the last bow hands and
said he thought that white should have a
win in the serve in this ending even
though it's not a totally clear cut
thing and you cannot just say okay you
play this and this and this and black
resigns still it's probably a win but
it's not not easy to do there was so
also a couple of tricks along the way
that I want to try to quickly point out
this is one of the tricks check check
okay eight King u6 here this is one of
the tricks here white should not grab
that a six-pound not being too eager as
rook h3 all of a sudden poses some
awkward problems here white has to play
Bishop edge for and just give up a piece
yeah I mean he has a couple of porn so
it's not like white is losing here
immediately but it's something that you
would rather want to avoid yeah and I'm
just brought this back preventing any
book h3 business it looks a bit slow but
it's probably not a matter of time this
position you just have to find the right
maneuvers a5 is a move that looks a bit
questionable on general grounds as it
becomes under fire post potentially from
the bishop but as I said I cannot really
give you a complete analysis see if
there's some kind of miracle draw that
black might have and he avoids it maybe
he can defend tougher if it's not
playing at five but still I feel that
there should be there should be a winner
ok the next interesting little point is
this why should not take on a five as
king to be seven is trapping trapping
the rook it's quite a funny position
yeah white can maybe just about draw
here but it's not a great idea to grab
the porn so he found this instead Bishop
to age four and allowing the king note
yeah here we go and black is running out
of mix after rookie seven kayak in
resigned it's a it's completely over now
and you cannot go into this ending as
after these moves you put into a
complete suit swine yeah you will lose
the bishop now as you run run out of
moves so a great win by island in an ER
completely yet a technical masterpiece
probably he did not seem to have a huge
advantage it looked like there should be
some draw defense by black but it's very
hard to prove and ultimately kayaking
couldn't hold it and we know already
from this tournament and other events
what kind of tough defender Russian
player is so yeah excellent effort
Barnett who is again back in the lead
with a plus to score right after his
loss there in the in the round before
against kawana is back in the lead with
the plus to score we're kayaking is
falling back to a plus one score yeah a
very nice round here's round 11 I hope
you enjoyed the coverage and also will
watch the remaining three videos that
I'm going to make for the final three
rounds it will be a tough tough finish
very close one thanks for watching